irgendetwas stimmt nicht mit dieser welt
in der sich marco unvermittelt wieder
befindet ohne zu wissen wer ist und wie
er hierher kam erst nach einem moment
erkennt er was ihn stört alles um ihn
herum besteht aus würfeln
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen meinungs- video ich hab ja
vorgestern das video mit dem j bb king
finale hochgeladen gestern dass miley
cyrus work und die veränderung von stars
durch druck drogen keine ahnung
medienpräsenz und was alles und ich habe
gedacht ich könnte ja eigentlich immer
mal so wenn ich irgendwas hat worüber
ich gern reden würde könnte ich euch
einfach einen gameplay hinterlegen und
dazu über irgendwas quatschen und zwar
geht es heute um einen minecraft roman
und dieser roman heißt würfel welt von
karl olsberg
den bekommt ihr eigentlich in allen
möglichen buchläden wie vor ein
schreiben was ich nicht aber so weil sie
nicht was gibt es in der branche gibt es
da ist wieder ganz verschiedene
buchhandlungen die als gänzlich haben
das buch heißt wir gerade schon gesagt
wölfe welt und handelt über minecraft
ist als länder mehr auf dem cover und es
ist halt ein roman über minecraft und
der hat bei amazon schon gewohnt schon
so oft gekauft das ist echt heftig da
gibts sowas von viele kundenrezensionen
das ist unglaublich und diesen alle
super gut und immer so empfehlungen wie
zum beispiel spiel nun schon sehr lange
minecraft und habe nach produkten
gesucht damit zu tun haben leider war
ist alles entweder spielzeug oder
kleidung dann habe ich zwei machten
keine feier bekommen und nach büchern
gesucht blablabla außerdem ist das ende
eine leseprobe lalala jedoch sollte man
minecraft spiel um das zu begreifen oder
halt aber trotzdem spannend bis zum ende
perfekt für minecraft liebhaber super
buch recht empfehlenswert also sind echt
super super rezensionen hat immer fünf
sterne das ist echt krass
ich brauche euch ein link in der
beschreibung ich bekomme kein geld von
diesem karl olsberg oder vor dem verlag
der das gemacht hat irgendwie um das
jetzt hier irgendwie vorzustellen oder
so sondern ich habe es einfach gesehen
weil das ein aus meiner skype liste drin
hat dazu meinte er ich glaube das kauf
ich mir
aber ich find's einfach ich weiß nicht
ich finde ein buch über einen spiel
finde ich immer so viel interessanter
als ein buch was ganz normales und dann
wird das buch verfilmt oder verspielt
das finde ich irgendwie so uninteressant
mein handy hat gibt so jedenfalls kann
jedenfalls wollte ich halt echt euch
dieses buch einfach vorstellen
und das tolle ist bei amazon könnt ihr
auch einfach so ein paar seiten lesen
die ersten drei vier seiten und es gibt
so ein paar sachen wie zum beispiel ich
hab ihn schnell raus gehört zum beispiel
habe ich überhaupt augen ich bin nicht
sicher
ich kann nicht blinzeln aber immerhin
sehen ich mache einen schritt der sand
fühlt sich warm an
doch als ich zurückblicke finde ich
keinen fußabdruck kein wunder ich habe
ja auch keine füße meine beine
viereckige stangen die ich nur an der
hüfte vor und zurück fliegen kann enden
wie meine arme in quadratischen fläche
ein bild blitzt aus dem vernebelten
tiefen meines gedächtnisses auf
transparent und flüchtig wie wasserdampf
ich bin auf einer kostümparty ich trage
eine ritterrüstung das
heruntergeklappten visier seines helms
behindert meine sicht arme und beine
stecken in plastikröhren ich stolpere
über einen am boden liegenden gegenstand
eine bierflasche und schlage ihn jemand
lacht nicht aus das war in einer anderen
welt voller weicher und vollkommen nach
vorn
damals hat sich die stahl verwüstung
fremdartig angefühlt auf einer
rechteckigen lied maßen wirken so als
hätte ich die anderen andere besessen
man kann hier echt eine menge seiten
einfach vorlesen
ich lese ich nochmal die buchrücken vor
und zwar irgendetwas stimmt nicht mit
dieser welt in der sich marco
unvermittelt wieder befindet ohne zu
wissen wer ist und wie er hierher kam
erst nach einem moment erkennt er was
ihn stört alles um ihn herum besteht aus
würfeln
verfolgt von skeletten zombies und
explodierenden gurken wesen muss marco
einen ausweg aus der würfel welt finden
denn er ahnt dass nicht nur sein eigenes
leben bedroht ist ein außergewöhnlicher
fan fiction romane der welt des spiels
minecraft von bestseller autor karl
olsberg
ihr könnt euch hier warte sieben seiten
glaube ich angucken
es ist immer noch ich weiß nicht ich bin
voll geflecht davon dass es davon sein
buch über sogar so eine gute bewertung
hat also ich habe es mir bestellt
einfach nur damit es vielleicht durch
lesen kann und eine zusammenfassung
darüber geben kann und ihr könnt euch ja
einfach auf bestellen also der link ist
wirklich in der beschreibung und ich bin
halt echt keine personen die einfach
sich ein buch nimmt und liest da bin ich
halt lieber dann am pc und gucken wie
videos an
oder schon irgendeinen film von dem von
dem buch wenn ich zum beispiel alle
harry potter filme gesehen und feiert
ist spielen und feiere die serie übels
aber ich habe kein einziges buch von jk
rowling gelesen ich habe zwei drei mir
gekauft aber ich habe nie so die geduld
gehabt mir das durchzulesen welches ein
film immer viel kompakter finde weil ich
finde dass man durch ein buch lernt man
natürlich einerseits ursachen kennen wie
zum beispiel die gefühls ausdrücke und
so was alles und noch viel mehr als
durch den film wenn man in dem film
dessen unterschwellig wahrnimmt aber
einem film durch musik und so was alles
wird halt noch sehr sehr viel stimmung
erzeugt und in buches ist zwar anders
aber ich denke dadurch dass wir alle
minecraft gespielt haben alle die dieses
video gerade schauen kennen minecraft
mehr oder weniger und das ist davon
jetzt zum buch gibt das finde ich sollte
eigentlich sich jeder mal zulegen und
ich meine es kostet fünf euro 497 ist
eine kostenlose lieferung das sind
anderthalb döner und das teil 2 dürner
leute da ist eben einfach einen tag
einen döner und dann oder erstmal keinen
weg menüwahl mac mini kostet 30 cent
weniger
damit stellt ihr euch mal so ein buch
weil auch wenn es einfach nur hat das
ist auf jeden fall gut und zwar
irgendwann wenn die langeweile habt ihr
ja was kann ich denn jetzt machen dann
lest einfach dieses buch wisst ihr das
hat 168 seiten glaube ich moment moment
den 186 seiten ist es auf deutsch
und das ist jetzt auch noch nicht so
lange draußen ist genau seit zwei
monaten draußen und ich mein ich find's
einfach aber wenn ihr euch das kaufen
bindet ich bekomme wie gesagt nichts
dafür dass ich das irgendwie vorstellen
ich dass ich rede bekommt ja wohl was
dafür bekomme gar nix da könnt ihr von
mir aus auf dem karlsberg gegen die
anschreiben und ich weiß niemand wer das
ist ich hab's halt nur entdeckt und
dachte jetzt dass ich das euch
vielleicht vorstellen weil das ist sein
buch ich habe schon mal ein buch
vorgestellt vor einem jahr oder vor
einem halben jahr
das war das buch heraus wo man in einer
spielwelt gefangen ist bzw
man muss man kommt nur im spiel weiter
indem man aufträge im echten leben
ausfüllt und das ist so weit gekommen
dass sich so viele leute von euch das
buch gekauft haben
dass mich die autoren bzw der autor von
airbus angestoßen hatte meinte ja danke
schön und so weil es war wohl nicht so
viele exemplare davon bei amazon
bestellt das war echt heftig und ich
packe euch einfach linken beschreiben
ich bekomme auch durch einen amazon link
nix ich bekomme nicht gar nichts für
dieses video
ich verstehe euch nur dieses buch
vorstellen ich hoffe einfach dass ihr
eventuell dadurch so ein bisschen weil
sie nicht so lust findet am lesen ich
habe einfach keinen bock am lesen aber
das buch habe ich jetzt bestellt und ich
habe mir die sieben testseiten hier auf
amazon alle durchgelesen könnt ihr auch
machen ich will das jetzt nicht alles
vorlesen aber es klingt auf jeden fall
so interessant weil es spiegelt so quasi
bekennt dass ihr geht in minecraft welt
und ihr seid da und es stimmt dass alle
erstmaliges bonhoeffers macht jetzt wo
bin ich denn hier ist gar keine
anleitung ich gebe einfach hin und
schlag jetzt bisschen holz und machen
das und das wird halt perfekt
dargestellt mit dieser mit diesem
charakter den ich steve als sondern halt
marco und weil sie nicht also ich finds
ja geil
also gameplay im hintergrund ist jetzt
auch vorbei ich bin wie gesagt keine
person die lebt aber ich hoffe einfach
das buch wird mich glaube ich fesseln
ist jedenfalls was heißt fesseln ich
werde glaube ich ganz feiern das buch
deswegen ich habe euch meine
beschreibung gepackt darüber wo ich
einfach mal lesen und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder gibt eine bewertung
ab wenn es euch gefallen hat schaffen
wir eventuell 3000 daumen hoch dafür das
ist jetzt an minecraft buch gibt es gibt
schon mehrere minecraft ist so eins auf
deutsch von einem deutschen autor und so
was alles ohne ihn wir aus dem
englischen übersetzt sodass keine witze
rüberkommt also schaffen wir 3000 daumen
hoch und treppen meine kommentare was
das letzte buch war was ihr gelesen habt
das wird mich auf jeden fall
interessieren weil ihr sind vom verstand
her genauso weit wie ich sage ich mal so
öl riesen chance so nach dem motto na ja
jedenfalls torleute